Chick-fil-A makes more money than
McDonald's Starbucks and Subway
combined and their first day in business
they made fifty dollars and today they
make over five people
I love Chick-fil-A
I love their sandwiches I love their
desserts I love their milkshakes I love
their waffle fries I love their sauces I
love their tenders but what I love even
more than that is their business because
there are lessons that all of us can
take in terms of how they do business
not what they talk about socially but
the actual business of running a
business and how you go from 50 to 5
billion and I can promise you it's not
by doing what everyone else does and
they did that without raising tons of
debt they did it over 76 years they did
it after the founder died and have
continued to grow and they never had a
down year where they went down in sales
for 76 straight years they sell one
quarter the amount of items of any other
franchise Subway has seven and a half
percent net margins their royalty alone
is 15 of Top Line meaning their stores
are running 20 30 plus percent margins
in brick and mortar food and they do
that being open only six days a week
having 52 days a week that they are
closed unlike any other franchise no
franchise he can own more than one
location unlike any other store they get
sixty thousand applications a year and
they only award less than one percent of
those people a store and they do it with
arguably a very controversial social
setting that would never work in a
publicly traded corporate company that
has to massage its PR so here are the
lessons that I take away from
Chick-fil-A that I've tried to apply at
as many different places in the
portfolio companies that we own and even
just at acquisition.com at the holding
company number one is that they sold
chicken sandwiches for 76 straight years
and I don't think they're going to stop
having singular focus on the core
products and not getting cute and not
getting fancy and not having 49 menu
items but just saying what are the
things that the most people want and how
do I get better and better and better at
doing those things because better gives
you leverage it means the same input
gets you more output rather than having
lots of different things you have to put
input in you just put more and more and
more because you only have so much Juju
if you had two items you can only split
test them half as much as you could want
for example if you think about this like
an Olympic runner the difference between
first place and fourth place in the
Olympics is a tenth of a second but the
difference between first and fourth for
a person's life
massively different we get these
outsized returns by making these
marginal improvements of being better
rather than being new despite our
entrepreneurial desire to have not a
chicken sandwich we're like what about
tacos
what about Burgers right like how many
times could they have done something
like that but they did it because they
knew that they wanted to stick to the
essential few and they knew that focus
is what was going to compound over the
long term
despite being publicly criticized for
not taking on debt and not trying to
grow faster for talking five six seven
eight years having somebody beat him
Boston Market remember Boston Market
when they had their rotisserie chickens
and the mac and cheese and all that
stuff they took on a ton of debt grew
super super fast and then imploded
Boston Market shot up and then shot down
because he wasn't thinking on a five or
a ten year time rise if Esther Kathy has
literally sold chicken sandwiches from
the time he was 25 until the day he died
he was a missionary not a mercenary he
wasn't doing it to brag about his ego he
was doing it because he believed that
this way of doing business was what he
wanted to represent I know that the
likelihood that my competitors are going
to be here in 70 years is almost zero so
if I build in a way that I'm going to be
here in 70 years I will win by default
and I think that's powerful because so
many people want to say they're number
one the question is when you look at the
richest man in the world I want to be
the richest man in the world you got to
respond to somebody's answer with for
how long
because eventually you die what are we
aiming towards for him he wanted to
build an amazing Chicken Franchise his
legacy outlasted his life and for me
that's my dream My Hope Is that whatever
we build can continue and not only just
stay alive but grow Beyond us and that
you can only do through a mission not
through a mercenary cause because if
you're just chasing the money people get
deluded out because there's always a
shiny easy win that distracts from the
core items the fact that they don't let
anyone have more than one store I think
there's a lot of wisdom to this so there
are lots of people like let me let me
open a hundred and they're like no
because you're not gonna be able to
focus we want someone to put their heart
and their soul into their location and
treat it like it's their own while he
was alive you have to have worked at a
Chick-fil-A I think they loosened that
up because you wanted to create a way
for people to come in mopping floors
flipping burgers going all the way up
and then eventually own their own
franchise he has profit check now mind
you he doesn't share the whole profit
but after he takes his pieces off they
have an ability to make more money and
having that kind of I'll say uncapped
earning potential for somebody is very
inspiring but he keeps it constrained to
a singular Focus because they know that
somebody can give it their all at one
location they've already tested that
they've learned over the years and I
think there's a lot of wisdom in that
that we can take for our own businesses
number four sang No on Sundays means
that you have to say no to things that
are obviously going to make you money
but will detract from your values and so
there are lots of opportunities on
entrepreneurship and you probably have
some on your docket right now that
you're like I don't know this is a
little left of center but like such an
easy win imagine the new CEO comes into
Chick-fil-A tomorrow and says you know
what I found a way to make us 13 more
sales and have most of that drop to
bottom line they're like What's your
amazing idea and he's like we're going
to be open also on Sunday
it would be such an easy play and
imagine how hard it is to say no because
in the beginning he had to say no to an
extra 13 on a million dollars it makes
it another hundred and thirty thousand
but when 13 is 650 million dollars
and you still say no it means that
you're appealing to a higher power
something above the money values matter
more than just about anything in my
opinion if they are true to the founder
true to the business and they operate in
that way and I would say that
Chick-fil-A is a great example of a type
of company that believes in its values
through and through and they practice
what they preach pun intended now I also
believe that appealing is something
above the money long long makes you more
money but you have to say no in the
short to get the long yes
one of the things that permeates any
Chick-fil-A if you've ever been there is
that they have a culture of service
you're one separate way from an awesome
lunch meal it'll be a pleasure serving
you at our drive-thru window after two
more things you know what that is just
gonna beat you guys are awesome one and
two yeah
all right thank you Chick-fil-A and so
what they did was they actually studied
the hospitality industry and even hired
people from Ritz Carlton to help them
create an Exquisite experience
at Chick-fil-A es true Kathy noted that
when he wanted everybody in his team and
his company starts saying my pleasure it
didn't change until he changed how he
spoke he's trained all of us to always
respond to thank you by saying my
pleasure so if somebody wants a refill
my pleasure people will learn 10 times
more from watching what you do than
listening to what you say and so if you
say hey we're all about being on time
here but you the CEO are late it will
never work we have to pick the very few
values that we know that we will never
break that we will always stick with
which is why values have to be true to
you not nice words on the wall because
they have to be things that you would
actually live otherwise they are
meaningless if you want to have a
business that grows even longer and
bigger you want to have a compounding
vehicle built within the business
Chick-fil-A has a compounding vehicle of
capital within their business whenever a
store creates money they have the cash
and they can pick the next location they
buy the land and they buy everything
itself too so they get the high return
and they get some tax benefits and so if
there's ever areas in the business that
we can get some kind of compounding
effect where money compounds on itself
that is something that I always try and
build in every business that I have is
how can I get this money that I'm
getting today to make me even more
tomorrow within the structure of the
business not taking the money out and
putting into stocks or putting it into
just like a random fund or whatever it
is but actually saying within my
business where I have active control
where I get the highest returns based on
my skill and my competitive advantages I
get higher returns and that's how these
guys build Crazy wealth that beats the
market
ruthless prioritization on the essential
few items that they need to sell the
fact that they haven't changed their
menu in decades should be a testament to
the fact that we as entrepreneurs want
to change it all the time there's a
Henry Ford story that I think drives his
home he was looking at a marketing
campaign and he had been working on it
with his Executives Etc three or four
months in he walked past his marketing
cmo's office and was like hey when are
we going to stop running that out he's
like I'm so tired of it and the
marketings I've looked up to him he was
like you haven't even ran it yet and so
the thing is is that we have all these
things that happen in our mind because
we're always iterating like we assume
everyone knows everything about our
products we assume everyone's already
bored of it because they're talking
about chicken sandwiches 24 hours a day
but reality is that most people might
get Chick-fil-A once a month right as a
treat the customer's perception when we
change something slowly in our mind
every six months as a small business to
a customer it just feels like it's
constantly changing there's no
consistency people value consistency
people want to know that when they
exchange money they're going to get the
thing that they liked last time and if
you make the same thing the same way
over and over again it also gives you
the opportunity to improve move it if
you have to improve a hundred things
it's a hell of a lot harder than
improving two or improving one and so
you've heard me say one product one
Avatar one channel for anybody who's
trying to make their first million
each one of these stores if you think
about them as a single business like
that's how they're thinking now do they
have drinks yes Etc the principal behind
it compared to everyone else in the
marketplace they have a quarter the
amount of things on their menu compared
to McDonald's and they make twice the
money they have such a refined menu
because it makes the order process have
fewer mistakes in it it makes the
drive-through process happen faster
they're able to have less food go bad
because they don't have to have all
these extraneous options they follow
Proto's principle of 80 20. they know
that 20 of their stuff creates eighty
percent of their sales they have all of
these efficiencies in there because
they're not trying to be cute they're
trying to be the best at a handful of
things and by doing that they've been
able to sell way more than anyone else
does with a way more constrained menu
and do it so much more profitably
there's wisdom there and so I try to
think about that is like okay even
though I could do those things should I
and most times the answer is no I should
just get better at the thing that's in
front of me and confront the problem
that I have which is how can I sell more
chicken sandwiches whatever your chicken
sandwich is and to drive even further on
the phone Focus they have even at a
micro level within their core product
the chicken sandwich if you compare that
to McDonald's Big Mac or Burger King's
Whopper
McDonald's big now has six ingredients
the Whopper has seven not including the
bun now compare that to Chick-fil-A's
sandwich which just has butter pickles
and chicken that's it they even have
half the ingredients on their
one-quarter sized menu because even then
they get more efficiencies at the
ingredient level they make it faster and
easier to prepare so it's more
consistent and they're able to do that
with greater economies of scale and they
can make the process itself leaner and
faster and leaner and faster and then
you do that for 76 years and become
unbeatable so one of the things that
when they were asked why are you so
limited in their in your selection
besides all the reasons I already gave
their response was that every time they
added another item they just saw their
sales of their main thing declined so
they're just splitting some sales off
the thing their core products and so how
many of us have opened a new thing got
people to switch from the old thing to
the new thing and now you're doing two
different things for the same amount of
money
sound familiar happens all the time and
so it takes the discipline to say no and
say we're just gonna get better the last
piece that makes them exceptional I
think is their VP of growth who was
talking about this you said 80 of what
fast food restaurants do between each
other is the same but I wasn't hired
here to do the same thing to the other
80 are doing I'm hired to do what the 20
are not doing that much more efficiency
has been driven into how can we improve
this business because if we change
nothing about this business we sell the
same 12 items you just get better and
better and better at the same thing they
even do practice runs in an indoor arena
for the drive-through to test in real
world scenarios to see how they can make
the drive-through more efficient and
increase the accuracy that's the level
of detail that the kingpins can do
because they've been doing it for 70
plus years the biggest takeaways I see
from the big companies that I try to
apply to my own business is what is a
business that I could be in for a
hundred years I believe that if you only
try and solve the same problem for 100
years you get pretty darn good at
solving it after Kathy lived that and
then he I mean technically even died
that he took one concept a chicken
sandwich and thought how can I just do
this one thing that everyone understands
better than anyone else and he built an
Empire and he built a mission behind it
that I think millions of people are
happy and frequent every day he has
edged his way to now being number three
and likely will become the second
biggest food chain in the entire United
States